Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica
Now I know its been a while, I was busy with PAX
But I got something to show ya. WELCOME TO BUBBLE BUTT ISLAND!
I know it's not much to see. This kinda looks like a dick pointing out at you, but I built this base.
but I built this base - not that this is
the base that's going on the island - it's
not the island base that we're talking
about here. This is the base that acts as
a precursor to the base that we are
about to build on this island. Now, what
took me so long is that I needed a lot
of preparation time and that included
making this area for, uh, this staging ground
for the rest of the island that we're
about to build in this episode. IT'S HAPPENING NOW,  IT'S FINALLY GOING DOWN,
GOD DAMN IT sorry something I forgot.
EVERYTHING IS FINE , DON'T WORRY, DON'T
PANIC NOTHING'S WRONG, DON'T LOOK AROUND YOUR HOUSE, there is no problem I was
panicking for nothing so I i've got the
list up here because I forgot to get the
list of people that are going on the
brand new lockers because as you can see
we've got a new array which means that
we need new names here the first one
goes to Stephanie Stumpf who was very
concerned about my dehydration prau
problem so thank you very much Stephanie Stumpf, uh, for enjoying the series the
next one goes to Emily Kuehn, who uh just
said they binge watch the whole series
so far in can't wait to keep it up with
real-time and a chance for a name on a  locker
which you definitely get, so im gonna put
Kue-Kuehn howeve-however you pronounce that...
I have no idea but thank you so much
next one to Coral Browne who says he was
very concerned about me ramming things
with the U.S.S. Fuck A Duck, and I know for
a fact that little submarine is designed
to ram things with its face... or it's dick so
anyway this is going to Coral- Coral
Corl Brwn. Coral Browne, good enough
for me :D. The next one goes to Anne Hayes
who helped me name this island and a lot of you guys out there were suggesting
bubble butt island, but she said: "I really
wish bubble butt was here, he was a very
good helper" and if you remember Bubble Butt from SOMA... aww...he was just a little
a little delight
I loved Bubble Butt so much, he was amazing!
Ok, so the last one goes to Fonsi Ba- Baragan
Fonsi...Fonsi Burgen, Fonsi Burgen who  said "Your fascination is scrumptious Mark, I
wish you good luck with the curse of the Emporer" ,which if I'm not mistaken there's
going to be an update real soon that
adds the Sea Dragon Leviathan which is
separate from the Sea Emperor, they're
two different entities but rumor has it
that the Sea Dragon Leviathan is
actually the creature that's going to be
in those abandoned lava pits er- the um
the...unused lava flow there's gonna be two
different locations that are added in the
near future
the lava caverns are going to be finished out, the one that was in the last episode
and then there's gonna be a new place
was like a bone graveyard you're gonna
go down there and you're going to see
some massive and I mean enormous
skeletons of creatures so that's gonna
be coming in an update very soon but for
right now we've got potted plants that
we need to fill with local soil before
it becomes night that's the first thing
I'm going to do because uh my food
situation is going to be a little
precarious here now I will come clean I
had to use some debug commands to get
enough material to be able to build
everything because, Good God if I had to go
out and farm everything by hand to build
that precursor base just to be able to
build a goddamn castle on this island
like Tom Cruise in Casta- no I i mean Tom Cruise not Tom Hanks because I'm
going to be like if if 'cause if  Tom Cruise was
stuck alone on this island I have a
funny feeling he'd be much crazier and
much more like how I is going to be
while I am alone on this island with no
one by the name of Wilson to keep me
warm at night  so anyway I'm trying to go up
I need to get some food out of the
potted plants and I know there's one
high up in this observatory here so that
I'll be able to populate mine and then I
won't have to worry about food so much
that I will die
because dying is something that I'm very good at in this game and I don't want to be
doing that while you guys are watching I
mean you guys have seen me die all over the
place like in every other episode that
I've done so I don't know why this one
would be much different  I've already opened you get out of the way. Please? AWW COME ON! git out
are you are you serious?! I'm gonna be
thwarted by god damn container how the
fuuck is this- are you serious here? Move! thank you!  Euh! Aight thank you very much ok oh yeah I forgot
I left a cooked hoverfish here that's no
good
OK so I'm gonna get the hanging fruit just get a bunch of those I don't think
there's any other fruit available
there's the melon plants that are in
planters down below but I dont know, no actually I forgot there's no fall damage
WEEEEE! Oh is there fall damage? oh there might be fall damage. Nah, there's no fall damage
For some reason, gravity is reeal low on this island so now that I got these,
you'll see that if I interact with these
potted plants over here actually I'm not
a hundred percent this is how it works 'cause I've never done it before this all new
territory for me but if I put this
whoops, if I eat that, haay NICE! Thats  going to grow into a TREEE
eventually I mean not
immediately now but its gonna do okay I
suppose I probably should have given it
some more room and maybe some more
sunlight and be ready access to water
and maybe I should be more concerned
about the rest of the things that I've
murdered in my past because that's
prolly gonna scare these things from
growing but anyway so in these various
things in this where I used the console
commands I've got just a slew of
different types of building materials
gold diamond copper silver a lot of
titanium nothing in there just yet and
also some water and first aid kit so the
only thing that I really need is food
and these are going to take care of it
when I find some god damn melons on
these god damn Island everything it's OK
so here we go the first step is to
build the foundation of my new castle ON THIS ISLAND!
Now im a little bit (lip smack) perturbed
about things but I'm gonna be ok so I
need a lot of titanium I need quartz to
be able to do this I'm gonna get that
much quartz I need some glass I know
that for a fact I probably need some
silicone I can't remember exactly but it
just it's a lot of titanium is gonna be
so I'm just gonna fill my inventory with
titanium as I can okay so this is a BREAKING NEW GROUND HERE
also these devices they make uh
med kits every 30 minutes so it's awfully
convenient so I just never run outta
meant nevermind I just my inventory is
full they disappeared into the ether I
don't get those great! OK so that's a
good start to what I'm doing here
the other thing Im gonna do is im gonna
put the terraformer in mah hotbar
and I figured out how to put things in
my hot bar and provide myself with the
perfect location with which to start my
Empire and its gonna be up here because
I think it's a good perch I don't want
to build it all the way up to the island
although the the eventual goal will be
to make this connect to that Observatory
up there, and thats gonna be a biiitch to do I'm going to
be doing this for a  god long time using
oodles and oodles of console commands but I'm gonna get it so
here we go where the frick am i going alright
okay all right right here
here IS WHERE I LAY THE FOUNDATION to my glorious future I don't know
if this is gonna be able to connect to
anything else at all because it seems to
be in the wrong orientation for one but
that's not going to stop me when has
being correct ever gotten in my way?
UUGGGHHH well good who I think that'll that'll do
go either way
okay I did it YAAY first steps! first glorious steps
I'm just gonna build a foundation around
this thing so that I have plenty of
space with which to build my Empire has
God no...
wow that is not that's that's not in
line at all there we go that's a little
better... OK so now that I got the foundation planted and we firmly just so we firmly
committed to this horrible atrocity tha- i
cant get up there, fuck! god dammit I did I just?
aww I walled myself off from-AWW POOPY BUTTS it's a good thing I know how to get rid
of that I forgot that I could just terra
form this entire island to get
everything out the way eh build there
we go
OK building there we go this is I guess
how god dammit stupid mushrooms get out of my way
OKAY.  *breaks the game* AWW WHAT HAVE I DONE
TITS!  OK alright OK mmm there! We made it I've got my
smooth handicapped accessible ramp which
is regulation standard up to my god damn
foundation and this goddamn foundation
is gonna sprawl...TO THE EMPIRE
THAT I'M BUILDING! ERRYONE LEAF ME ALONE IM TOM CRUISE ON AN ISLAND
It doesn't make a lick a sense where -pph- where are you trynna be? Where are you trynna be?
Why won't this just, really is that that the only thing that
I can do here really entertain this
thought right here let's entertain this
AWW! IVE GOT SOME SHADE! Who needs a tree when I've got a foundation over my
head that is sound science right there
all right, Phase one completed, which is
trying not to kill yourself so I did
that I'm not dead and hopefully I'll be
able to move forward from here with goodness and graciousness and gracefulness
OK so the entrance to the castle is
slightly compromised and there's a
there's a few trees that are going to be
intersecting inside my god damn castle
at least my god damn castle is god damn
standing that's all that matters
WOO! *burps* Ah there we go! Sorry, burped.
Booink! There, Now we go inside
yeah it's got some natural lived in
fauna look to it! I like the vines that are
already creeping into my life! Let's just
get some glass so that we can observe
all the wonderful wonderfuness, that is
our view! Oh look at that! I can almost see the sunset through few
leaves oh there's a bit of sky isn't
that wonderful I am doing great I'm out
of glass!
good thing I-no, my fabricators over
there. Holy shit, I have made some grievous errors...
things went so much better ignore that
turdmonster over there things went so much
better when I was trying to build these
while I was able to think to myself
exactly what I'm doing whatever its fine
just it's totally fine,  no one need to worr- OH LOOK AT THEM! They're  growing!
Isn't that delightful? *crazed laughing* OK so we got those, everything's fine we got potted plants
a-growing like crazy we *huggh* we got
materials out the wazzoo and so now
need to go back to my god damn island
that so god damn easy to get to
Bubble Butt island is being a bit more of a pain in the butt then I thought it would be
alright I sure wish I could see things
oh I know I can build lights and we can
do that because I got power
I can do that not that I don't need to
comfy chair I mean I would love a
comfy chair the moment but I don't need
a comfy chair
OK so if I build this right heeerre
*long silence*
Bueh!
How do I...
Turn on!
Oh, what the hell?
Where you goin?
Whe-It's a spotlight?
Oh okay! That's- that's not horribly... what are you doing? That's not at all horribly useful
I don't see how that's gonna help me in
any way. Aight hang on. What the hell- oh I stopped its cone of light
I feel like I did something horribly
wrong
OK so let's try this again little-little
better hopefully alright try this
Yeah, Yeah, YEAH! Not creepy at all! I thought it would have
been better on land but apparently we're
just gonna be terrified no matter where
we go there are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing are you ok
It's still alive!  Oh man things are going so
horribly wrong for me
Okay. Yeeup.
This woulda been (illegible babbling)
Its almost as if these buildings are meant to be made
underwater and not over water because overwater isn't actually term that
people use and I'm just an idiot
heheheheheh
Da da dadadada is that good?
I don't know if thats good
Does that help meh-
does it help anybody? It certainly doesnt help me!
How much do I have left
Two titanium! Enough for one more-
Oh hello handsome!
How are you doing? *huhps loudly* Daa fuck
*hehups again* Daa shit
Well, can't do that.
Welp can't do that either.
Ah tits, I have- oh hello
How are you doing?
That's where you went to!
Woah, this episode is going off to the worst start,
that I ever thought ok all right so now that it's starting to turn into day...at least I hope it is
because if not holy shit this- what is you anyway? Why are you glowing red? Ugh it's kinda cool but
terrifying the same time
OK so we made exactly one unit of
progress getting this castle and if you
guys can go by anything of this and you
can judge how long it took me to build
the god damn like staging area before I
was gonna build a castle but I'm gonna
build its gonna be nuts because I gotta
get above it and that's the only problem
getting above it is a bit hard because I
wanna places up there but for some
reason the game don't let me do that
very easily because it almost as if it
is anticipated that I was swimming in
the water and to build above! It's fucking hard, man!
Okaay. Cool beans, going for it, shiiiiiiit
Okay! Good enough! Good enough good enough!
There we go! We have two story building I want
to get one more story in there but I
barely have enough stories as it is why
can't I place that whys why why why
Sir? Ma'am? Why is that not acceptable?
Placement? It's a perfectly good room
you're dicking with me now oh you're dicking with me
We're gonna have hatches going every which way cause I just need to get in there and I
god dammit
AH!!
[chipmunk voice] [whoa whoa whoa]
[ okay fell down, no good ]
[ come on now ]
[ Behave! behave for me. behave, behave, behave ]
[ it's like - it's like taming a wild animal, this thing ]
[ okay, that's not - ]
[ - okay ]
[ whoa! okay, okay - ]
[ - ah shit ]
[ whoa! AAHHH!!! ]
[ AAHHHHH- boink. okay ]
[ whoa - pa, wo-woapa! ]
[ wo- AH FUCK!]
[ stupid goddamned *?* made out of goddamned dirt ]
[ and not working properly. what's happening to me? ]
[ AAHH! Fuck that! ]
[ What the fuck?! It's just like "maybe you shouldn't- *incoherent words*]
Hello Goodbye OKAY!
There we go!
Now that, is a tower!
It's a parapet!
and I don't know what a parapet is, but I know that castles have a lot of them
and they talk about them all the time.
It's all that I've ever heard from ancient history,
Is about how big their parapets were
So I made the biggest parapet
because I'm the best
so I just need to make ladders in between each one because I waa I'm not stupid!
Well I mean I am of course very stupid in everything that I'm doing in this game
But, in this particular moment I'm not stupid!
YEEAAAHH!!
Okay.
So
Damn it i need more titanium.
UUUGGGGHHH
*warming up*
BOINK! Okay
So now that we got enough, and we got the lights all going and we got the power going
Ehm, I need to get more solar panels because this lights strong *burps*
Sorry again, dammit I'm grosssss
DON'T LOOK AT ME I'M DISGUSTING
Okay, boink!
There's another one!
Boink
Okay, we're doing good!
We got these in here were almost at the tahp
Almost at the top floor and once we get up there I'm actually gonna put windows all around the sides
so that we can see everything
in the nearby countryside
because we can see the entirety of our kingdom
so that we know what we have to look forward to.
And we have to look forward to a LOT
because there's a lot in our future!
WE ARE CONQUERERS!
WE ARE
literally alone on this island forever and ever and no one is here to help us
and excuse me I'm just gonna
I...I don't have enough... I don't wanna go all the way down to get more glass
just so I can finish this out
I wanna finish this this out so I can finish this episode and tell you guys
that I HAVE BEGUN
THE PROJECT which will consume my life
and in the next episode I'll be a bit further along in my castle
and I'll have something more to show you and then hopefully there's gonna be
even more updates throughout the game
but you can see just about everything from here
all the way to the Aurora, to the mysterious not-island
which I think you can see it out to the left that little line there maybe
I have no idea
But either way,
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
Subnautica WILL continue we've got a lot more stuff in store for you.
so thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you In the next video
BUH-BYYEE
*outro music*